N
THEY JUST KEEP PLAYING HARD
EVERY NIGHT.
MONTY HAS DONE A FABULOUS JOB
AND IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO WATCH
THEM.
>> WE MENTIONED A TAR HEEL IN
THE HOUSE.
>> YES.
YES.
I SAW YOU CHUCK.
I SAW YOU HAD THEM ON TODAY.
PUT THE SNEAKERS ON TODAY.
I AM UPON NOT LOSING.
I AM TOUCHING THE WALL, SHAQ.
YOU CAN GET THIS CUT.
ISN'T THIS WHAT YOU WANT IN
LIFE.
>> CHUCK.
>> THAT IS ME ON THE RIGHT.
>> THE ONE ON THE LEFT LOOKS
MORE LIKE YOU THAN THE ONE ON
THE RIGHT.
>> I THINK THAT IS MY SENIOR
PROM PICTURE.
>> WITH THE TEXTURIZER.
THE LITTLE S-CURL GOING.
THE LITTLE S GOING BACK IN THE
DAY.
YOU TALK ABOUT CAM JOHNSON WHEN
HE WAS IN COLLEGE BASKETBALL I
TRIED TO BUILD A PERFECT PLAYER.
I WANT TO HAVE HIS RIGHT HAND.
HE SHOOTS THE BALL SO
INCREDIBLY.
EVERY TIME HE SHOOTS THE
BASKETBALL, I THINK IT IS GOING
IN.
YOU ARE PLAYING WITH DEVIN
BOOKER.
HE GIVES YOU SPACE.
THE OTHER THING, HE IS PUTTING
THE BALL ON THE FLOOR AND
GETTING TO THE RIM.
FREEZE IT HERE.
THAT SHOT HERE WASN'T A
CONSISTENT SHOT FOR HIM IN
COLLEGE OR IN HIS FIRST COUPLE
OF YEARS IN THE NBA.
THE IN BETWEEN SHOT HAS MADE HIM
A DEADLY PLAYER.
WHEN YOU PICK-AND-ROLL AND WHEN
YOU LET HIM GO AND GET SPACE.
YOU CANNOT GIVE HIM SPACE.
YOU HAVE TO STAY WITH THE
ROLLER.
HE HAS GOT THE THREE.
HE HAS GOT THE IN BETWEEN.
HE DOESN'T SETTLE ANYMORE.
HE GETS INTO THE AREAS, DRIVES
THE LANE AND FINISHES.
SO HIS ABILITY TO SCORE IN
MULTIPLE WAYS IS THE BEST THING.
I WAS READY FOR YOU TODAY,
CHUCK.
>> I DIDN'T WANT TO BREAK YOUR
CONFIDENCE THIS EARLY IN THE NEW
YEAR.
>> I AM NOT LOSING A RACE IN
2022.
>> OKAY.
>> I SAW YOU.
>> YOU STILL HAD THE MUG IN YOUR
HANDS.
>> I TELL YOU WHAT, WHAT ARE WE
BETTING ON THAT?
>> ANYTHING.
>> NORMAL BE